FRED SAUER: Hello, everyone.
I'm here in the studio today
with Iein Valdez, colleague,
developer advocate on AppEngine
as well as myself.
And today we have two really
special guests with us.
If you've been following the
AppEngine blog in the last
couple of days, you saw
that we had a couple
of guest blog posts.
And we actually have those guest
bloggers with us today.
So we have first Steve Huffman
who is the founder of Reddit
and Hipmunk.
And Steve has been teaching a
course online at Udacity, a
free online university.
And so we have Chris Chew from
Udacity who's a senior
software engineer there.
And today we're gonna talk to
them about their experiences
of building course material for
Udacity, building the site
itself, building the
course material,
working with AppEngine.
And we'll have a chance for
you to ask questions on a
moderator page.
So let's bring in Steve first
and let him to do a little bit
more formal introduction.
And then we'll get cracking.
Steve.
STEVE HUFFMAN: I, uh--
FRED SAUER: I'm sorry.
You were muted for a second.
Go again.
STEVE HUFFMAN: Oh, OK.
Let's try that again.
OK, so.
I'm Steve Huffman.
I am one of the founders of
Reddit, and more recently one
of the founders of Hipmunk.
I've been a web developer
basically my entire career,
all seven years of it so far.
And then this past spring, I had
the opportunity to teach a
web development class
with Udacity.
At the end of this course, I
really wanted students to have
the ability to build their
own web applications
and get them online.
And Google AppEngine
was instrumental in
the success of that.
Actually went into the class
not knowing anything at all
about AppEngine other than
basically that existed and it
might help us with want
we needed to do.
And by the end of it, I
came out a total fan.
The course was a success.
AppEngine is great.
It was a really fun
experience.
And so now I've turned into
something of an AppEngine
evangelist, I guess.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Well, thanks for coming
to the program today.
I was gonna ask you what your
feeling was when you started
out and how it worked out.
But it sounds like at
least the end result
was a pretty good.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about how you felt about
AppEngine going into it with--
STEVE HUFFMAN: Sure.
FRED SAUER: --a lot
of unknowns?
STEVE HUFFMAN: So basically what
I knew about AppEngine
going in is that it was this
Google product for building
web applications without
dealing with the sys
administration.
So you get a basic web framework
and you can deploy
your code and it would magically
be online and it
would magically scale and you'd
have this data store.
There's a lot of magic
basically.
And as a developer, right, one
of the things you learn is
that you should be aware
of magic, right.
There's always something
lurking under there.
So.
But what we wanted to accomplish
with the course was
I wanted to teach people how to
build web applications, not
teach them how to be
sys administrators.
Didn't want them dealing with
installing MySQL and Windows
and that sort of thing.
So, it sounded like on paper,
and after like a cursory read
through of the documentation,
it sounded like it would do
just about exactly
what we wanted.
But I hadn't actually ever
really used it myself.
So, we went in with some
question marks basically.
If this thing is as good
as it says it is,
it's gonna be perfect.
But as a developer, right,
the documentation and
implementation seem to be
implemented by very different
teams of people.
But in this particular case, I
was pleasantly surprised at
just about [INAUDIBLE]
at how things worked.
And when I was [INAUDIBLE]
things the first time just to
see like will this basic
application get online, I was
actually really blown away that
the deployment process
worked on a first try.
Because I've spent an
embarrassing amount of time
over my career deploying code.
So it was actually a really
cool experience.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Good.
Can you maybe talk a little bit
more about your background
as a developer?
Like, where did you start?
What was your road, like, to
getting to this point where
you wanted to teach
this course?
STEVE HUFFMAN: Sure.
I mean, programming has been my
life's passions since I was
a little kid.
I got started when I was, I
think, eight years old or so
typing in programs out of
magazines into GW-Basic.
And all through high school,
I loved to code.
And I studied computer
science in school.
Me and one of my college
roommate, Alexis, we started
Reddit immediately after
graduating from the University
of Virginia.
And that was actually
my first time really
developing on the web.
I had a passing knowledge
of HTML and CSS.
And I had dealt with a SQL
database maybe once or twice.
So that was a pretty
good trial by fire.
Fortunately, Reddit never had
hockey-stick growth, right.
It grew slowly but surely over
the last seven years or so.
But, we learned a lot of things
the hard way from how
to scale a database, how
to migrate stuff.
Going from one app server to
two app servers was a big
challenge for me.
I didn't know what the
heck I was doing.
And going from two to whatever
they're at right now was also
a huge challenge.
And so, I've learned a lot
of lessons, a lot of best
practices, the hard way.
And that whole experience
was a lot, a lot of fun.
And I wanted to basically, in
this course, try to share some
of those experiences so people
don't have to make so many
missteps that I made.
And AppEngine, actually, it's
funny because it abstracts
away a lot of those
bad decisions.
It makes things a lot more
straightforward so you can
actually focus on the actual
software you're building.
And I feel like on Reddit, I
actually spent a lot of time
focusing on ops and not
on Reddit itself.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
That certainly rings true with
what we've heard from other
developers.
And that's kind of the mission
we set out when building
AppEngine when we launched
it several years ago.
So, I'm glad to hear that echo
back that that was the
experience.
STEVE HUFFMAN: Yeah.
Ops are fun.
But it's one of those
things, you know.
Leave that to the pros, right.
And Google, like you guys
are the pros, so.
As me, it's like when I was 20
years old, why should I be
messing with this stuff?
I've never done it before.
Google, they're the
world's experts.
FRED SAUER: I guess my own
experience is ops fun when
you're on one server.
STEVE HUFFMAN: Yeah, exactly.
FRED SAUER: And as soon as you
get to two, it starts to
become annoying.
STEVE HUFFMAN: I mean, it's
fun when it's working.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah.
I was actually curious if you
could talk a little bit about
Python and how that was as
a language, some of the
frameworks?
And then how it was like to
actually build the content?
STEVE HUFFMAN: Yeah.
So, Python's great.
You know, when I actually
started Reddit, Reddit was
written in LISP.
And when Aaron Schwartz joined
us, he was a big
Python guy at the time.
I was thinking to myself-- or
thinking out loud rather--
we should rewrite Reddit because
the stuff we have
right now is trash.
And he's like, well, we should
rewrite it in Python.
And I was like, OK, sure.
What the heck.
I had never done
Python before.
So we rewrote Reddit in about
a week in Python.
And basically, Python has been
my main language ever since.
And I love it for a
lot of reasons.
The main reason is that
it is unlike LISP.
It is very difficult to write
bad code in Python.
It's a great language
for teams.
It's very readable language.
And when you're working together
in a team, being able
to read other people's
code is so important.
And we also developed these
picky feelings about web
frameworks.
At the time, Rails
was blowing up.
But it was just way
too magical.
Like it hid so much from you.
I really didn't like it.
Django was just getting
started.
There was a couple others
we looked at.
But every time we tried one of
them, we would find ourselves
within a couple of days
feeling boxed in.
So we ended up making our own
framework called web.pi, which
basically mapped some URLs
to some handlers.
And you had to explicitly deal
with get and posts and headers
and cookies.
And we felt like that was the
perfect level of abstraction
to deal with.
And by a very coincidental
twist of fate, AppEngine
actually shares some lineage
all the way back to web.pi,
which was really convenient
for me.
But I think it's the right level
to be working at as a
web developer.
You should understand
how the web works.
You don't need to have these
simple tasks hidden behind
these complex abstractions.
And so a simple framework, a
simple language, everything
nice and simple, I think, is
a really nice quality about
Python the way we are doing
things at Reddit, and then the
way things work at
AppEngine now.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
That all rings true that you
want simple abstractions as a
programmer so you can put
the pieces together.
But you also want to be close
enough to the metal that you
could actually make the
engineering trade offs that
you need to make in order
to make it site
performance and scale.
STEVE HUFFMAN: 'Cause every
site's a little bit different.
And what makes a good site great
is how you deal with
those unique challenges
you have.
And being able to do that
is supremely important.
FRED SAUER: Yep.
So I think you started talking
a little bit how it was
building the course.
How did maybe Python play in,
and how did AppEngine play in?
What was it like building this
course and going through and
creating that material
for the students?
STEVE HUFFMAN: So, it was
actually a lot of fun.
And so once we realized that
AppEngine was going to work
out, we constructed the course
the way we did, which was
basically at the end
of each lesson--
there were seven lessons
in total--
at the end of each lesson
there'd be homework.
And the overarching kind of
arc of the course was
basically build a blog.
And so we could say, add this
feature to your blog.
So the first lesson was
basically get a hello world
website online, which if you
knew exactly what you're doing
could take as few
as five minutes.
And if you've done it for the
first time, it still shouldn't
take more than an hour, which
is really impressive for
getting anything online.
And lesson two was forms,
getting forms and
validation and stuff.
And the nice quality about the
way we've structured this is
to submit your homework, all you
would have to do is submit
us a URL of your live
website online.
And then we could have our
grading scripts just go hit
your website and verify
that it's working.
And so I think then we got into
basic databases and then
user accounts and then some
kind of scaling memcache
stuff, that sort of thing.
And I wanted the course to
be immediately useful.
I wanted the students to have
gone through these experiences
of implementing accounts, of
implementing caching, of
validating form elements.
Because those are all the things
as a web developer you
do over and over
and over again.
And it was a really
nice opportunity.
I feel like web development is
one of those rare pieces of
learning where you can be
instantly useful after a very
short amount of time.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
Well, you certainly have
something to interact with,
and it's live on the web.
STEVE HUFFMAN: Yeah.
It's very gratifying.
FRED SAUER: I went through the
course myself, and I really
thought the notion of submitting
a URL where you had
completed your assignment, or
your mini assignment, was a
really good way of keeping me
engaged and pulling me along
the different steps of the
course and say, well, just do
this one more thing and you
can get to the next
step and the next.
So I thought it was
very engaging.
I like it.
STEVE HUFFMAN: I'm glad
to hear that, really
glad to hear that.
FRED SAUER: So you talked about,
I think, some of the
features you liked on AppEngine,
the built-in user
accounts and the caching.
Were there other things that
stood out in this platform as
a service offering that were
really beneficial?
Either thinking back
to the days of
building Reddit or Hipmunk?
Things that you use today that
would have saved you maybe a
lot of time?
STEVE HUFFMAN: Oh, absolutely.
The big one is the data store.
At Reddit, and to a lesser
extent at Hipmunk, I feel like
I've written our own kind of
like ORM, no SQL thing on
postgres half a dozen
times now.
And it gets a little bit
better each time.
But the data store is
really, really nice.
Once you start thinking in like
I can't do joins, I need
to structure my data this way,
it's really, really nice.
And data store's nice from
two points of view.
And this actually really
surprised me.
The first is that you just don't
have to think about the
scaling issue.
It just works.
I was really surprised
at that.
The documentation doesn't go
into great many details about
how it works.
But I guess if you've built it
a few times, you kind of
understand which strategy Google
has taken with this.
And, the other thing was that it
allows you to develop very
fast, right.
The whole no SQL argument,
right, is that you don't have
to be constrained by a schema.
You can kind of add features
as you go, which is part of
the culture web development,
right.
Think of half a product and
build it and get it online,
and then write the
other half later.
If you have to do a data
migration every time you add a
new feature, which we did for
the first couple of years at
Reddit, it's so painful.
It's so painful, especially if
you don't know how to do data
migrations.
So not having to think about
that would have been a
tremendous advantage.
I feel like I spent probably
half my time over the course
of Reddit thinking about how are
we gonna store this data?
How we're gonna access
it quickly?
How are we going to scale it?
And if I didn't have to think
about that, I could have spent
a lot more time just screwing
around on Reddit, which would
have been nice.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So you mentioned not having
to do data migrations.
And I think people who have
built it scale or have built
sites that have been around for
a little while as they add
features maybe have thought
about this.
But maybe not all of
our viewers have.
Can you maybe talk about how you
in practice add fields to,
essentially, an existing scheme,
or how you restructure
the data store without doing
a migration, without
taking the site down?
STEVE HUFFMAN: So a big
challenge when you're using
kind of a traditional approach,
or the kind of naive
approach that you might learn
from a web tutorial, is that
simply adding a column
to a large database
is not always fast.
Actually most modern systems
it's pretty fast now, but it
wasn't necessarily
the case then.
But let's say you want to
restructure Reddit comments,
for example.
They're threaded.
There aren't really good
kind of tree-like data
structures in SQL.
So you have to kind of
create the systems.
It's like, so, are we gonna pull
out all of the comments
for a particular story and sort
them in memory and then
display them?
How is that relationship
gonna work?
How do we get a fast list
of everybody who's
voted on this thing?
How do we sort all of these
stores in real time?
Those are things that aren't
really SQL problems.
And so you kind of have to
work around SQL to do it.
And for optimization, what
we basically do is we
de-normalize everything.
We store things redundantly in
all sorts of different places
and in a different tables and
on different systems so
everything's fast.
If you take the kind of the more
the data store approach
where you can kind of your data
as you're going to use it
or you can store your data in
the place that it needs to be
and if you change the way you
want to use it, all you need
to do is store it a little
differently.
It's much simpler.
It's a much easier way of
thinking about things.
You don't just grab this blob
of data out of the database.
If you try to distill everything
into a simple query
of basically by ID.
You can convert everything into
a by ID query, things
cache really nicely.
Things scale really nicely.
And if you're doing that simple
just get me item with
ID x and all of a sudden that
item has all of the data
you're gonna need for x, it's
really, really convenient.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
I hear that one of the hard
things for people coming from
a relational SQL background is
this notion of giving up
normalization.
And they fight it initially.
And I went through this myself
when I was first going into no
SQL scalable databases.
I constantly was trying to
normalize my schema.
And when I finally gave that up,
then this whole new world
opened up of kind of what you're
describing of hitting
the sweet spot of everything
is a fetch by ID and the
systems performing
fast and cache.
All those things you mentioned
just suddenly come together.
STEVE HUFFMAN: And the code
actually gets simpler, too.
Everything gets actually
much more simple.
You just have to think
a little bit.
Sometimes it's tricky.
Sometimes you have to fold your
use case into this thing.
But now it's funny.
After doing it for a few years,
the notion of designing
a table, it's just ugh.
I don't want to spend time
doing that today.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
So this one question that I
always ask developers--
at least ones that I talk to
initially when they're coming
to work on AppEngine and they're
struggling a little
bit with the no SQL world, and
because AppEngine is a little
bit different or the no SQL
world is a little bit
different, it feels like an
uphill battle because.
It's something new that they're
learning that they
haven't been exposed to.
But I always try to come back,
like six or eight months later
when they've built their site
and had some time to play with
it, and ask them is this new
world harder or is it easier
than it was?
And I'm curious what
your answer is.
STEVE HUFFMAN: I think it's
absolutely easier.
Because the hard parts about SQL
is that SQL's designed in
the general case to
solve problems
that aren't web problems.
It's really good for
like dealing with
spreadsheet-like data.
But when you have this
case where like--
on Reddit, we built this
database called thethingDB.
And it's because everything
was a thing, right.
Users and comments and links and
subreddits all had a lot
of the same qualities.
Have you ever tried to do
inheritance in SQL?
It's a nightmare.
And so once you can free
yourself from trying to force
your problem into a spreadsheet,
yeah, it becomes
much, much simpler because
sometimes you have to--
There are challenging aspects
to it which is, what
queries can I do?
The types of queries you can do
can be limited sometimes.
So that requires a little
bit of extra thought.
But it's a lot less thought
then, how do I represent this
non-tabular data in a table?
FRED SAUER: OK.
I appreciate the answer.
The answer varies, but it's
usually somewhere between both
worlds are about equally
complex.
Or it's more along the lines of
your answer where this new
world is actually easier.
And I think the answer tends to
be if people are playing in
a world where they're building
bigger apps and more scalable
things, they tend to find
the no SQL world easier.
And people who are still
building smaller apps for
themselves or for small groups
of users, these tend to find
them of roughly equal
complexity.
STEVE HUFFMAN: Yeah.
I mean if you're on
one machine, SQL
works pretty well.
There's still some constraints,
though, right.
Because if you make one schema
design decision and then you
want to change that,
that's troublesome.
If you have to care about data
types, it's nice not having to
care about data types
all the time.
Sometimes it's nice to just
store a blob of stuff and then
not have to think about
it again for awhile.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
So if you put yourself in the
shoes of other developers and
you're maybe coaching a friend
or a colleague on what
technology stacks they should be
using for maybe a site that
they're building, could you
maybe talk about some of the
different things they should
think about as far as choosing
technology?
STEVE HUFFMAN: When it comes
to choosing technology, you
can't go wrong using something
that somebody else really big
is also using.
And I usually use that as an
argument against things.
Don't use Mongo because
who big uses Mongo?
Don't use noJS.
Who big is using noJS.
Use Python.
Google uses Python, right.
Use postgres.
Use MySQL.
Use things that have worked for
other people in the past,
the battle hardened, tried
and true systems.
Because you don't want
to be the test dummy.
You've got more important things
to worry about than
will this thing scale
for my needs.
You want to be one Google search
away from answering all
of your problems.
You want to put yourself in a
position where you will not
have any problem for
the first time.
And so that's how we
usually think.
And a really good measure about
the quality of a piece
of software is how easy
is it to install.
If that thing builds on your
weird machine the first time
and the documentation is clear,
that's a really good
sign people have been down that
road a number of times.
And if you're using NODE and
half the packages have to be
installed globally and half of
them have to be installed
locally and it's screwing up
your home directory, you
should be thinking, ugh, maybe
this isn't quite as polished
as it should be for my
needs right now.
STEVE HUFFMAN: OK.
So, before we kind of jump over
to Chris to kind of hear
his take on kind of building
Udacity and his experiences
there, maybe can I leave a
parting question with you
which is would you use AppEngine
for your next
Reddit, Hipmunk--
I don't know what the third
in that series is?
STEVE HUFFMAN: Yeah.
It would absolutely
be, I think, the
first place we'd start.
Because when you're starting
a company, you should be
thinking about what is
your company doing.
You don't want to be thinking
about how are we gonna scale
this thing.
You just don't want to deal
with those problems.
The first three months of a
start-up are so critically
important, just launching.
Yeah, I would give serious
consideration.
And certainly if it was Reddit
or Hipmunk, both of them would
have of lived just fine
on AppEngine, I think.
Every problems a little bit
different, but that's
certainly where I would
start my thinking.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Great.
IEIN VALDEZ: I have one
more quick question.
Actually I was just curious,
sort of, now that the course
is up, people have taken it,
what's been the reaction from
people who have taken the
course on the platform?
Overall, like positive,
useful?
What's your take?
STEVE HUFFMAN: The sentiment
that's gotten to
me is really positive.
Now, I don't think people are
gonna be like, hey, Steve,
your course sucked So--
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, yeah.
STEVE HUFFMAN: --maybe I'm a
little bit of a biased source.
But, I think the enrollment
numbers are still pretty solid
and consistent.
I've met a handful of people,
including a couple of our
employees at Hipmunk who took
my course, which is really
nice because I kind of push my
agenda on people before they
even get through the door.
So that has been really nice.
And I'm really proud of it.
It was a really fun experience
and I love meeting people who
have gotten to learn from my
mistakes, get a year or two
ahead of the curve, and not have
to go through the same
pains that I went through.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very cool.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Great.
So we're gonna go over to Chris
Chew, senior software
engineer at Udacity.
Chris is gonna do a little
introduction.
I think he's gonna have a
demo for us for Udacity.
And then I think we already have
some questions queued up
for you Steve and for Chris,
and maybe for a
couple for us as well.
So at the end we'll
go through those.
First you want to start out and
just do a little better
introduction then I gave you.
CHRIS CHEW: Sure.
Hello.
My name's Chris Chew.
I'm a senior software engineer
for Udacity,
originally from Colorado.
I actually moved out here
to join Udacity.
So it's been an amazing
adventure to be part of
something that's making such
a big splash in the world.
And it's been fun to work
with people like Steve
and you guys at Google.
It's interesting.
AppEngine is actually a pretty
good fit for Udacity, and I'll
talk a little bit more about
what Udacity does.
But I would characterize a lot
of the first half of the
discussion in terms of the
application of AppEngine for
Steve's class is that
everybody really
enjoys doing things.
And people enjoy learning
by doing.
And that is absolutely
Udacity's mission.
We want to provide a
high-quality, higher education
based on the belief that people
learn best when doing.
And we really want to try and
redefining what that means.
And so we also want to give
people employable skills.
And one of the fastest growing
areas in the world would be
web development.
And so having a platform where
you can get people just doing
immediately within the first
five minutes of a course, you
can get people already working
on a project by putting up
their very first website.
It's amazing.
It really is a perfect fit for
us and for our mission.
FRED SAUER: Great.
CHRIS CHEW: So, Udacity was
founded by some people from
Stanford, along with various
other people that just really
wanted to try and disrupt
education.
Our mission is to provide the
high-quality, higher education
and to find ways to give people
employable skills.
I have some screen
sharing ready.
So I'll go ahead and start
sharing my screen.
Do you see our Udacity
home page on--
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
That looks good.
CHRIS CHEW: All right.
So our website is udacity.com,
of the home page.
We have a lot of courses.
So we have--
I think it's five or six that
are in development and some
where around 10 that are
actually out and live.
They're all completely free.
And they're all built-- or have
been designed and taught
by leading experts in the
particular field.
We're focusing on science and
technology, engineering,
mathematics, the stem
curriculums, I guess, because
that's what we know and that
seems to be kind of what the
world needs at the moment.
And how is it that we branch
out, I think, it's still to be
determined.
One of our most popular classes
is Introduction to
Computer Science taught
by Dave Evans.
And throughout the course
you learn Python.
And you actually learn to
build a search engine.
And students have actually
built all kinds of search
engines that started from zero
to scratch, went through the
course and built interesting
things.
Steve's class was Web
Development CS253.
And people actually start with
no web development experience
and put up a working website
that adds value to the world.
A really interesting one that
I was just looking again at
yesterday is somebody who built
something that looks at
tweets and defines some
sentiment and analyzes that,
particularly around the
upcoming US election.
So here's the overview page
for Steve's course.
It talks a little bit
about Steve and what
the course will do.
And you can just start it any
time by previewing the class.
Or if you enroll, we'll start
remembering your progress.
And at the end, you can actually
get a certificate.
Courses are based around
small lectures.
We try to add as much
interactivity as we can,
broken up by quizzes.
And quizzes aren't graded
at the moment.
And it's just a way
to make sure that
you're following along.
And the course builds up to
final projects at the end.
In which case, Steve's
course, it was
actually building a blog.
And we assess that by actually
sending out a request to your
AppEngine app-- or it could
be any app really--
and deciding whether or not the
blog is actually operable.
So that's the, I guess, you
asked the overview.
Do you have any questions
in particular?
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
Well, to get started maybe, you
heard Steve kind of talk
about his experiences.
And I wonder if the way you
think about AppEngine kind of
aligns with Steve?
And what experiences did you
have kind of along the way?
CHRIS CHEW: Yeah.
I think it does very
much align.
Although, lately I've been
focusing more on the longevity
of an AppEngine application
as opposed to just
getting up and running.
And the interesting thing about
AppEngine is it actually
does both pretty well, and
better than most things.
My background, I've been a web
application software engineer
for 13 years now.
I had started actually building
Access databases, and
then got into the web by
putting them online
using PHP and MySQL.
Since then I've been responsible
for applications
in seven or eight different
languages, probably 15, 20
different stacks.
And so I came to Udacity with a
pretty broad range, I think,
of skills as it pertains
to the stacks.
And, I also pretty strong in
the [INAUDIBLE], as Steve
calls it, the understanding
file
descriptor limits on a Linux.
You know, stupid things
like that.
And I came to Udacity actually
hoping to take us away from
AppEngine, quite frankly.
I was skeptical, like Steve.
I didn't know enough about it,
and my experiences with it had
been vanilla, I guess.
And actually the opposite has
happened in my time here.
I turned into a big
fan of AppEngine.
And it is absolutely the best
place for us to be.
And it's very surprising.
And it really does force you
to make the right kind of
scalability decisions
from the get go.
And whereas Steve can talk
about that transition of
learning those things over the
years of scaling is hard.
And so to be able to
just do it from
beginning is really nice.
FRED SAUER: Good, good.
I'm glad to hear that.
Can you maybe just help--
I know you talked about this
in you're guest blog post--
but maybe describe you're stack
to our viewers today and
what does it look like?
I think you have some custom
libraries in there.
CHRIS CHEW: Yeah, we do.
We've actually had to do a lot
of work, I think, to improve
our code over--
so we've been live on AppEngine
for about 10 months.
And we've seen some amazingly
crazy spikes in volume.
So, it's been really
nice to be able
to handle that traffic.
But even then, we definitely
don't feel like we handle it
as well as we should.
And so we've been doing a lot
of refactoring of our code
into some libraries so that we
can kind of ensure that we're
following the best practices
of AppEngine.
One of those is creating a
persistence library that wraps
on top of the new NDB library.
We're in Python.
And that adds some things,
like helps us manage
references a little bit.
'Cause with a data store you
do kind of move away from
relationships, and you
kind of look to have
things in key values.
But the reality is things
really are related.
And we do have to manage some
consistency around that.
And that's the downside to a
bunch of key value pairs.
And so that library helps
us manage some of
that a little bit.
Also a big component in that is
some kind of event driven
sort of processing that allows
us to do some deferred
processing so that when one
value of one key changes and
we need to update a series of
others, we have a framework to
run the code that can make the
others eventually consistent.
FRED SAUER: OK.
CHRIS CHEW: On top of that,
then, we have a REST kind of
framework we call TRAILS, which
is also developed by
[INAUDIBLE]
Kaminsky, one of our
engineers here.
And it's a really nice--
it's actually, I think,
the nicest REST
framework I've ever seen.
It's a joy to work with.
It's very easy to build families
of RESTful resources.
And then after that, it's
all HTML and JavaScript.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Great.
Maybe can you share some of
the questions that you get
from others.
When you tell them that
Udacity's running on
AppEngine, what sort of
questions do you get?
CHRIS CHEW: Yeah.
So, a lot of times it's
disbelief or surprise, I guess
surprise more than
disbelief, but.
And the first question
that comes up is,
what about the speed?
And I think the truth is it's
a little slower than if you
were building something on--
if you put servers some place
and were running things low
level with a simpler
stack, it's
absolutely gonna be faster.
And that's a trade off that
you get for the horizontal
scalability.
And we do experience
latency spikes.
And we're working through
figuring out why those happen,
and then what we can do
to minimize those.
And we're learning there are
things that we can do to
minimize them.
And so that's the growing
pains that you get with
AppEngine, I think, would be
learning how to minimize
latency spikes and organizing
your code and your data
structures such that you don't
have that as often.
And so, that would be the first
surprise is how do you
keep your site fast?
FRED SAUER: OK.
So, I remember in your guest
blog post talked about a few
things that you were looking
at to kind of reduce the
latency of various requests
in your application.
I know you already mentioned NDB
which adds memcache-based
caching for free, instance
caching--
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah.
FRED SAUER: It has the tasklet
support, that sort of thing.
Can you name one or two other
things that maybe you're
doing, looking at?
Is it restructuring your code?
Is it doing more requests
or RPCs in parallel
asynchronously, braking
up task queues?
Like, what are your main
strategies that you're kind of
focused on right now?
CHRIS CHEW: Yeah.
So the overarching strategy is
to be able to fulfill each
request with the least amount
of work possible.
And so that means we've
basically taken the idea of
normalization and
turned it to 11.
Everything is de-normalized.
We have a lot of duplicated
data.
And we're really trying
to kind of--
I keep calling it
pre-materializing views--
kind of take it from an
Oracle background--
where we try and get the data
to be ready to be read as
quickly as possible.
And so, in order to do that,
we have a ton of deferred
processing which sits on
top of the task queue.
And we've actually monkey
patched some of the NDB stuff
to allow us to be able so that
when something's written to
the data store, we can send
something into a task queue to
let other code know that it
needs to update other parts of
the system.
We're starting to use the NDB
task list, the co-routines, a
ton to try and fire off things
in parallel, and also give the
process opportunity
to handle other
requests at the same time.
And I think that's a trend
that's happening in web
development everywhere.
I mean, noJS or [INAUDIBLE] and
Python all those things
are really taking advantage of
the co-routine of patterns or
cooperative programming.
Then I think the other
thing we've--
so we actually have a couple
layers of cache on top of NDB.
We actually have an in-process
cache for some things where
consistency's not
as important.
And we don't use
as much memory.
Our apps are actually,
surprisingly, have low memory
footprints.
So we're trying to use more of
that with in-process caching
on keys that are gonna be
more predictably read.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Good.
Iein, I know you're already
kind of looking
at questions here.
Do we have some good
questions?
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah.
We have a couple questions.
Some of them have
been touched.
Let's start with Steve.
There's a couple questions
for Steve.
Maybe the first one here
is from anonymous
person which is--
STEVE HUFFMAN: Hopefully
not anonymous.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yes.
Which is, do you plan to
continue teaching at Udacity,
perhaps a follow-up
course to CS253?
STEVE HUFFMAN: It's something
we've talked about.
And I think I'm on board with
doing that and I think
Udacity's on board with
doing that as well.
Presently, my head is basically
in the sand at Hipmunk.
But when my load lightens
up a little bit, yeah.
There's definitely a few gaps in
the current course that I'd
really like to fill.
Yeah, potential another
course or two.
That would be interesting
to explore
down the road certainly.
IEIN VALDEZ: Great.
That's good to hear.
And then we have another
question for you from Udi
which is, which concepts were
the hardest or trickiest for
students to understand?
And then, what would you
change to overcome that
difficulty?
STEVE HUFFMAN: For students
to understand?
The database stuff is tricky
because, I think, really to
get a good grasp, it just
requires time, right.
You just have to be thinking
in databases for a while.
So that's challenging.
Certainly some of the concepts
are really hard to teach
because coming up
with meaningful
quizzes can be tricky.
A lot of like the basic HTML
stuff was actually really
tedious to try to teach.
And some of the scaling concepts
are hard to express
in a video and hard to capture
in either a simple quiz or a
simple web app.
But by and large, I think we
managed to get to the high
points pretty well.
But as with anything, if you
take a seven unit course and
spend maybe 100 hours on it or
so, it still takes thousands
of hours to become an expert
in anything, right.
So, some of the trickier
concepts just
take time, I think.
IEIN VALDEZ: Cool, cool.
OK.
And then one more question
for you which
is someone's asking--
[? Varun ?] is asking-- how easy
would it be for someone
to learn PHP and
MySQL instead?
I guess this is probably in the
context of your course.
What do you have to
say about that?
STEVE HUFFMAN: I think
a lot of the
concepts are very similar.
We tried to not make this an
AppEngine tutorial, but have
AppEngine facilitate
the concepts we
were trying to teach.
Now some things will
be tricky, right.
You've got to get
MySQL running.
You've gotta get PHP running.
You've got to get those
two talking.
That, I think, will actually
be the hardest part.
When MySQL goes wrong--
or when you run out of--
as Chris was alluding to, one
day you're gonna run out of
file descriptors.
Those are the type of issues
that you're gonna have to deal
with at some point.
And those are tricky, right.
Those are challenging.
Things break in weird ways.
And that's the joy of being
an ops guy, I guess.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK.
Cool.
This looks like a question
for Chris.
I'm not sure if he can
answer or not, but
I'll just go for it.
Basically, the gist of the
question is this is around the
sort of copyright status
of the CS253 course.
Is it Creative Commons?
Can it be translated into other
languages and shared in
other websites?
This looks like someone in the
Russian Republic potentially.
I'm not sure what
the status is.
Do you have any comment?
CHRIS CHEW: Yes.
So, our courses are all
Creative Commons.
And as far as I know, we intend
it to stay that way.
We do actually have several
translations already.
And we absolutely encourage
translations.
That happened accidentally, and
it was one of the happiest
moments, I think, we had here
at Udacity that people found
our stuff so useful.
There's a website here.
And I can follow up on a blog
post on a Udacity blog or
universalsubtitles.org.
And we have a team
called Udacity.
So you can actually search
for Udacity there.
Or I can provide a link.
And that's the best place to
submit new translations.
And also the translations are
then put into our subtitle
system in YouTube.
IEIN VALDEZ: Cool, cool.
CHRIS CHEW: Yeah.
Please.
Translations would
be wonderful.
We'd very much appreciate
that.
IEIN VALDEZ: Fantastic.
OK.
Here's a question for Fred.
FRED SAUER: OK.
IEIN VALDEZ: Which is,
the data store quotas
seem to be quite low.
Doesn't that severely limit the
free usage for AppEngine?
What happens if it
goes beyond the--
FRED SAUER: So, yeah.
So with AppEngine, we've always
said that we want it to
be free to get started.
We want you to kind of start
experimenting with AppEngine,
be able to try it out, kick the
tires a little bit, before
you have to give a credit
card and enable billing.
And so we have two of the main
components that most
applications who have billing
enabled, they pay for, are
instance hours.
Those are hours that there are
app servers running your code
so that's when you're
getting traffic.
And the other is data
store operations.
And other smaller things
like storage
quota on disk and bandwidth.
The first two are kind of
the key components.
And so the free quota for
an application includes,
currently, 28 instance
hours a day.
It's a little bit
more than 24.
We want to give you some room
to kind of occasionally bump
up to multiple instances.
But it essentially let you run
kind of a small site easily.
The data store operations
are--
what we did is we kind of looked
at average use of lots
of small apps, and we kind of
picked a number there where we
thought, OK, most applications
should reasonably be able to
use the free quota and
be able to run.
So I have a couple personal
sites that I run under that
free quota.
They're just ones I use
with my family.
They don't get hit very often.
I don't have to pay for those,
so that's great.
There are a few kind of things
that people starting with
AppEngine run into quickly with
respect to data store
usage that catches them a
little bit by surprise.
And with just a few lines of
code changed, you can probably
reduce your data store usage
very significantly.
So one of the decisions we made
early on with AppEngine
in hindsight that was maybe not
quite the right decision,
but what we decided was the
properties on entities would
by default be indexed.
That is, so if you have a
customer property with a first
and a last name, by default we
create a first name index and
a last name index so that you
can do queries like find me
all customers whose last name
starts with Hoffman.
And hopefully Steve would
show up in that list.
Or first name with Chris, and
we would find Chris there.
But it turns out in this
non-relational world, that's
usually not what you want.
You don't want an index in
every single property.
You probably have maybe a dozen
or two dozen different
properties on an entity.
And you're not gonna run a
query against all those.
But every one of
those indexes--
there's actually two indexes,
an ascending and
a descending one.
And so kind of to wrap up
the story is by default,
properties are indexed.
And there's an extra penalty
that you pay as a user for
writing those.
And the change is very,
very simple.
When you declare your database
model, when you say first name
equals db string property, in
parentheses you just put index
equals false.
And suddenly you've reduced
the number of small write
operations by two just
for that one entity.
So every time you kind of update
that entity or you
create it, that's a reduction
right there.
There's another area where when
I get a chance to look at
code that other developers have
written, I very often see
that they're doing data store
queries rather than fetches by
key even when they know that
the result is gonna be a
single entity.
And queries essentially cost
twice as much work as a fetch
because you're first doing a
query across the index to
figure out what entities you
need, and then you're doing a
second phase of actually
getting the entities.
So right there with that trick
you can kind of cut your data
store big operations in half.
And then with the other
one, you can cut the
smaller ones in half.
So, short answer, there's some
low hanging fruit to kind of
address that.
And we think that the free quota
should still be good for
small applications.
IEIN VALDEZ: Cool.
So we have time for about
two more questions.
I have one here for Chris from
Evan in Oregon which is,
Udacity is an awesome
application and I'm excited to
watch it grow, but certain
oddities persist.
Each view of each course
requires greater than 300k in
monolithic JSON object.
Why not a more dynamic fractured
Ajax response to
avoid loading?
So, hopefully that makes
sense, that question.
CHRIS CHEW: I'm curious.
I think Evan might be a plant.
Yeah.
So, that has not escaped
our notice.
It's interesting that--
yeah, I mean, everybody makes
wrong design decisions at
time, and sometimes you just
have to make a decision.
Right now, when you pull down a
course, you load most of the
course content in one
JSON request.
And, I guess it's fewer
requests, and that's a bonus.
But our courses, I think, or
the content is a lot bigger
than what we envisioned at the
time of that decision.
And it ends up pulling
more down.
We're actually in the middle of
a rewrite that will go live
in January-ish.
And within the new system
we're definitely pulling
things down incrementally,
and the performance
is definitely improved.
So Evan please be patient.
We're working through
that refactoring.
And we're gonna give you
a whole bunch of other
oddities, I'm sure.
FRED SAUER: Sounds like fix
is on the way already.
CHRIS CHEW: Yeah.
I hope so.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK.
Cool.
And this will be our
last question.
This is from Kyle.
And this is for you Steve which
is, why do you think you
and Alexis were so successful
in the company?
Do you have any parting
thoughts on that?
STEVE HUFFMAN: I could talk
at length on that.
There are many paths
to success.
And for Alexis and I, we were
really close friends going in.
And we stayed close friends
throughout the entire
experience.
And when you're starting a
company, being able to lean on
your co-founder is supremely
important.
And one of the things that I
really loved about Reddit was
that Reddit was a company
with a soul.
And Reddit's personality
was our personality.
And Alexis and I, like, we're
fun to hang out with.
And Reddit, it was a
fun place to be.
And I think considering we
submitted all the content for
the first couple of months,
pretending we had traffic, we
were able to kind of
set the tone to be
things that we liked.
And so I think it really came
down to caring, letting our
company have a personality, and
letting that personality
be our personality.
And so, we considered
our users friends.
And if you've hung out on
Reddit, like, there's a good
chance you've interacted with
Alexis or I. And if you've met
us in person, we try to--
That was important to us because
our technology wasn't
very good, right.
The website was kind of ugly.
It was pretty jank.
It was down a lot.
It was slow a lot.
I was still learning how
to do all this stuff.
But I think we overcame a lot
of that by having a real
community and making
a place that people
really wanted to be.
FRED SAUER: Great, great.
I thought of maybe one
more question.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, yeah.
FRED SAUER: We can throw
that out there.
So I'll start with you Chris.
And Steve, I'll give
you a chance to
answer the same question.
So Chris would you ever go back
to kind of managing your
own machines, be it virtual
machines or real machines?
Or are you kind of sold on the
kind of platform as a service
model and just worrying about
application logic?
I'm biasing the question a
little bit, but I do want an
honest answer.
CHRIS CHEW: Yeah.
So, I would say that AppEngine
would definitely be on the top
of my short list in starting
some other projects.
There are some things that you
can't do in AppEngine, like
you can't execute arbitrary
code really.
And so, like our program
submissions here, when you
submit some programming
snippet, that
doesn't run on AppEngine.
We actually send that out and
run it at someplace else.
And so there are some projects
that you might envision that
it's just not gonna work.
And you might end up creating
some other hoops you have to
jump through when it would've
been net easier to do it
someplace else.
And the Amazon Web Services
has the Elastic Beanstalk,
which is kind of like the
instance deployment kind of
system that AppEngine has.
And so those are some
other competitors.
And you always have to be
aware of what your other
options are.
But as far as starting something
that actually has a
chance to stick with you
throughout the entire life of
a project no matter how popular
you get, even the fact
that there's a chance that
it'll work is extremely
compelling.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Great.
And Steve, would you ever go
back to kind of managing your
own servers, playing
sysadmin or--
STEVE HUFFMAN: I can tell you
what I would never do is I
will hopefully never install
a server in Iraq again.
Now, you know the difference
between AppEngine and AWS--
Hipmunk uses AWS now, right--
is whether you are actually
administering the boxes yourself.
I basically echo exactly what
Chris said is if I were
starting again or if I had the
opportunity to really move
Hipmunk, we'd consider AppEngine
for a lot of it.
But I know there are pieces
where it wouldn't quite fit.
And what I wonder is
will those pieces
exist at some point?
'Cause there's things like the
way we run batch jobs and our
[? Fare Alert ?] product and
we care about the IPs very
much and that sort of thing.
They're kind of little issues,
issues that I'm sure Google
could actually solve.
But, my instinct is to
say, I want to do
as little as possible.
So the more somebody does
for me, the better.
And AppEngine does
quite a lot.
But, we are not a company who is
gonna be made or destroyed
on our skills on ops, right.
We're not an ops company.
We don't want to think
about that.
We're a consumer web company.
And so as long as that's the
case, we want to outsource the
ops to somebody else.
Yeah.
FRED SAUER: Focus on
the value end.
OK.
STEVE HUFFMAN: Exactly.
FRED SAUER: Well, thank you very
much both you for taking
your time and sharing your
experiences with us.
I hope the viewers had
a chance to enjoy it.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah.
Thanks a lot.
FRED SAUER: Thank you.
STEVE HUFFMAN: Our pleasure.
Yeah.
Well done over there guys.
FRED SAUER: All right.
So, just to wrap it up.
If you followed the interview,
liked it, and you haven't read
the blog posts yet that Steve
and Chris contributed the last
couple days, do check
those out.
And we'll see you back here on
the Google Developers Live.
Thanks everyone.
IEIN VALDEZ: Thanks everyone.
FRED SAUER: Have good day.
STEVE HUFFMAN: Bye.